I'm Angela Eagle I'm the Labour MP for
Wallace II we've just written a book the
new serfdom what conservative ideas are
you attacking in the book well the idea
of the book is that it demonstrates the
often hidden influence of a philosopher
and economist called Frederick Hayek who
was mrs. Thatcher's guru who decided
that really the only way of making any
decision in in any country was to use
the price mechanism if you were to
preserve Liberty and yeah the very
extreme view of what I've called market
fundamentalism which has come to be the
dominant idea in the way our economies
develop since mrs. Thatcher's time and I
think it's actually led to a different
kind of serfdom than the one he was
warning about in the 1940s so why is
this influence hidden because I think
it's become all pervasive and a lot of
the assumptions that mrs. Thatcher kind
of injected into the way that we do
things in politics have just become
accepted and actually these ideas when
you examine them are completely
ludicrous and some of them are even
offensive so the price mechanism doesn't
work in many many instances for example
it has nothing to say about the needs or
requirements of anyone who doesn't have
any money
because their needs and just aren't
taken account of in any market markets
fail in many ways one of the other
things that Frederick Hayek felt you
needed in a society was really that to
recognize that people were motivated by
their own selfishness and greed
effectively and to maximize their own
utility and that if everybody did that
then that would provide the best
solution to any system we'll actually as
Democratic Socialist I believe that we
that's not true that people are also
altruistic and there are collective
beliefs and goods in society that I want
to see provided for everybody so I don't
think I've spent my life just utilize
you been sort of motivated by my own
selfish greed in fact I think a lot of
people in society give back to others
and they empathize and identify with
others
Fredrik Iook also really was asserting
the for a society to work properly and
from markets to work properly
it had to be unequal so that those who
were much poorer would strive and work
harder again I think that this is
profoundly wrong and immoral way of
looking at things and so the book is
about how those ideas have almost become
like wallpaper the background against
which every other decision is made and
what I'm saying is we should look at
these ideas for what they are and see
how much they've ruined our world the
market fundamentalist ideas don't take
account of social justice they don't
bring about inclusive growth which
includes everybody and they certainly
don't do a lot to ensure that the growth
that we have is sustainable in
environmental terms so it's time to move
on and so he was fighting against one
type of serf and you said yes his book
was called the road to serfdom and it
was written in 1943 it's very famous
rant against socialism of any kind and
he thought that Clement Attlee was the
most appalling person and he thought he
saw that the collective work that was
going on to fight Hitler during the
Second World War and thought that this
would lead to serfdom and my arguments
are that the values that he set out in
his book which have been put into effect
by Margaret Thatcher and not mitigated
enough subsequently have actually led to
a different kind of serfdom in our labor
market where people are expected to work
for very low pay
creating a society where we've got food
banks and where we can't just satisfy
the basic necessities for a lot of our
people for example for housing for
access to food and all of those things
and so does that mean that you because
you've talked about the fundamentalism
of economic theory and and often you
know the conservatives present
themselves as the only people who can
run the economy and they also present
these ideas as if there's some kind of
natural law and I'm saying actually no
we can make different choices that are
more collective and actually democratic
socialism gives us different sorts of
values and so the values I set out for a
different sort of society a democratic
socialist society are democracy Liberty
cooperation internationalism and
equality I think you can create a better
society if you put those values into
effect how do you hope for these values
to kind of materialize what kind of
policies do you hope to to be adopted in
the I suggest various different things
because it's quite a wide ranging it
dips into loads of different things
without without going into huge detail
about any but I think we need a more
empowering state we need to have the
idea of having a state that allows
people to develop their full potential
rather than seeing it as wholly bad
which the the conservative view usually
is you need the smallest possible state
but I think we need an empowering one I
think we need an an ethical taxation
system so I think people need to
disapprove actively of those that try to
avoid paying their fair share of taxes I
think we need things like wealth taxes
because at the moment in our system we
have one of the most unequal
distributions of wealth and income that
we've had in our history and it's
getting worse so I think you have to
look at things like wealth taxes closing
tax havens down so that people cannot
escape by sending their wealth offshore
participating in the collective
provision of goods and services like
roads and a judicial system but not
paying anything so um one fear with them
and taxing wealthy people in a global
economy is that they might just move
there and they might just give up on
Britain and move elsewhere and pay taxes
or not pay taxes elsewhere does that
mean you have to have an international
solution to the fact that large amounts
of wealth now are being put offshore so
people can escape their obligations to
the countries that they live and work in
and I think we've got to stop that
happening and you can do that with
international agreements to close some
of these these dark spaces down and I
think that people should as citizens of
a particular country be proud to pay
their fair share of taxes to enable
provisions to be made for everybody it's
part of being a social being and I think
that human beings are social beings that
have moral obligations to each other not
just their own selfish desires and I
think that's the difference the
philosophical difference between the
Frederick Hayek disciples and those of
us who want a democratic form of
socialism and more more collective
provision where do you hope for the
future of the Labour Party now it seems
like we're at a crossroad I want us to
be in government putting some of these
ideas into effects I think I'm a product
of previous Labour government's I was
the first woman in my family ever to get
the chance to go to university and I
went to Oxford it gave me chances and
opportunities that many many
working-class people got because of
previous labour governments and I want
to see those chances and opportunities
available to all regardless of their
social standing or wealth in the future
as well I think by working together we
can actually
transform people's lives and prospects
and you do that in in my belief with
labour governments and given that we've
just found out the results from the
European elections what does that mean
about Labor's position on brexit well
first of all I think brexit is a
profoundly reactionary thing I think
that those that push for brexit are
trying to create a circumstance where we
separate from the European Union and all
of the treaties that we've signed up to
which put a floor under workers rights
and environmental rights so that we can
have a kind of turbocharged Thatcherism
on the edge of Europe well this is a
reactionary project that I don't think
we should be supporting and we've got to
do our best to ensure that we mitigate
the effects so far we're in a situation
where I think that we need a clearer
position on how we move forwards we've
clearly fallen between two stools and
the election results last night which
are extremely disappointing
but some people want to Tober
Thatcherism to come out of brexit others
just want a kind of sovereignty right
the electorate of the brexit party is
not necessarily a factor right no no but
the people that are driving it I've got
that agenda and they told quite a lot of
lies in the election the original
referendum they said we'd get all this
extra money for the NHS and they did a
very anti-immigrant kind of pitch so
they were trading on resentment and fear
I think obviously we can be sovereign
and we used to hold our own in a
sovereign way in the way in which we
dealt with our partners in the European
Union if you trade a bit of sovereignty
you can have a bigger effect on the
global stage if you're talking about 250
million people rather than 60 million so
it's about how we amplify our
global influence and I think turning our
backs on our nearest neighbors and
somehow signaling that we don't want
anything to do with them it's not the
best way to try to deal with some of the
problems that the world is facing at the
moment final question you entered
politics as a young woman what's your
advice to young people thinking about
going into politics now well I mean you
have to know why you're doing it and
that's not about I don't think a career
it's about remaking our society to fit
the values that you share with others in
whichever political party are in
obviously women have a tougher time than
men in the way that I think that they're
treated by the media and all of that but
we've made huge strides in the 28 years
I've been in Parliament when I first was
elected in 1992 there are only 60 women
out of 650 in parliament and we've got a
lot more than that now so progress does
happen and I'd say try to be part of
that change thank you very much thank
you for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of arson ideas at iai TV
you